welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka Darth initial
and after being called all manner of
things from poopy head to neck bearded
basement dweller on my rise of Skywalker
video I thought it actually doubled down
on a bad decision and give my breakdown
of exactly why I personally didn't like
the film if you enjoyed the movie that's
fine
I like venom even though people hate it
you're allowed to like movies that other
people don't and I'm hoping here that we
can have at least a slightly educated
discussion about why I don't think the
film worked and what they could have
done to improve it if you can answer a
give reason to some of my criticisms and
I'd love to see that as I'm a big star
Wars fan I probably like one less Star
Wars movie than you do which is the rise
of Skywalker and I'd much rather enjoy
the movie with a new appreciation for it
then go on disliking it for the rest of
my life so yeah if I'm wrong let me know
with the new release Star Wars fans are
even more divided than they've ever been
and with people jumping to slam it while
it's others leap to its defense it's
time to re-examine the movie and discuss
why some people are labeling it as the
worst Star Wars movie ever now there is
gonna be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to watch the movie
yet and you just don't want anything
ruin it then this is your chance to turn
off without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
rise of Skywalker okay so before we get
into the part of the movie that I didn't
like I thought I'd discuss what elements
of the film I enjoyed because yeah I
think anyone would be pretty stupid to
say that nothing in this film worked now
I absolutely loved seeing Lando back on
the big screen Billy Dee Williams
brought with him an air of charisma and
charm that really elevated all of the
scenes that he was in seeing him ride
into battle at the end was awesome yeah
and I loved watching him return Adam
driver 2 completely knocked it out of
the park and he's actually quickly
becoming one of my favorite actors and
yeah every Kyllo scene was brilliant
watching his exchange with Han on the
Death Star was heartbreaking and even
though Harrison Ford didn't bother
getting a haircut it definitely felt
like the emotional high point of the
entire trilogy
was also excellent in this film like in
the past especially the force awakens I
kind of felt like he was just Han Solo
light and he was just put in place to
move the plot along rather than being an
actual character however here Oscar
Isaacs really gets his shine in the role
and the movie is a lot better for it
raised battle with a dark side to is
excellent and had they not shown their
hand and had a dark gray feature a very
heavily in the marketing for the movie
then I think the standoff with herself
would have blown me away in the theater
I also I also liked Babur Frisch's
laughs that was really good now on to
the stuff that I didn't like okay so
let's start with the beginning of the
film most notably the opening crawl that
kick starts almost every Star Wars movie
personally I fell at the opener for the
movie really just tried to cram in as
much information as possible and it's
clear that they didn't have any time to
set any of this up so they just bashed
in as much as possible into this bit of
text even the opening line which reads
the dead speak the galaxy has heard a
mysterious broadcast a threat of revenge
in the sinister voice of the late
Emperor Palpatine doesn't really work
for me
reviving a character in a line of text
like this is very underwhelming and lazy
to me and I was so surprised that it
came out like this that I actually went
back and scoured the internet to see if
there had been any setup at all in the
prior films or marketing material what I
found is that that actually had been a
broadcast of the Emperor's voice used to
set up this movie that had been put in
and I'm not kidding you a fortnight live
event now I'm not saying that it's a bad
idea to set up the entire premise of
your movie in a fortnight live of well
actually it's a very bad idea but I
don't know why we couldn't have had this
broadcast in one of the many scenes in
which kylo travels to X goal at least
put it somewhere in the movie at least
let the audience know why this message
is so alarming to so many give us a
feeling
show us the expressions on the actors
faces when they hear this for the first
time and realize that their worst fears
have come true or you know just just put
it in a fortnight live event instead of
the movie anyway next up is the fact
that the Emperor is back absolutely
nowhere at any point in
the film was this setup the original
director of the movie Colin Trevorrow
did not have the character in his script
and before he was fired he didn't have
any plans to include the Emperor at all
Ian McDiarmid didn't even know he was in
the movie till halfway through the
production schedule so yeah he
definitely wasn't supposed to be in it
my main problem with JJ is that he's
really good at taking things rebooting
them and making them a success in order
to allow other creators to come on board
and develop their own ideas this
happened in the case of Star Trek and
many of the directors work he's good at
kicking things off but what he's not
good at is actually writing and taking
things beyond the starting point the
force awakens was pretty much a remake
of a new hope and it's clear that JJ
isn't really an ideas man he very much
likes to pull from source material and
similar to Star Trek and Karn he's not
capable of taking things in a new
direction
the Emperor's back for some reason
because Snoke is dead and JJ just
couldn't come up with a compelling
villain he has an idea though why not
have kylo be the main villain and the
movie could revolve around trying to
turn him he's already had two films
setting him up and he's way more
interesting than this decrepit old man
who looks a bit like Princeville but we
won't talk about that the fact that the
Emperor is back cheapens Darth Vader's
sacrifice at the end of Return of the
Jedi and basically the emotional weight
the triumph that came from that movie
has now been stripped away just because
JJ can't come up with a new idea they
insult audiences and don't even explain
how he returned as they can't come up
with a reason I bet if you sat any group
of Star Wars fans in a room for 30
minutes they'd be able to come up with a
reason for why the Emperor was back but
nope they don't even bother to talk
about it
they just need him back and hope that
you're stupid enough to go along with it
because yeah
nostalgia this entire scene of Carlos
sneaking down to discover what's really
going on actually it kind of reminded me
of when you know you were a kid at
Christmas and you snuck downstairs just
try and get a peek at Santa Claus and
you came across your parents in it it
was them they were behind it all this
entire
I'm working from the shadows anyway
Palpatine revealed that he clones Snoke
but if he capable of cloning extremely
powerful force sensitive beings
why not clone Darth Vader that would
manipulate kylo way more than Snoke ever
could and once more you could continue
ruling the galaxy as you were
Palpatine wants kylo to kill ray but
then bring her in and yeah I get that he
was pushing her but why use kylo at all
just bring her in on your own Rey is
desperate enough to learn about a past
that she would go anywhere that may
reveal where she really came from
another big problem that I have with the
film is the entire tie-in between
Palpatine and race lineage the last Jedi
for all of its problems and yes there
were many did stay that anyone can be a
Jedi anyone can be special even a little
broomstick boy you know it's a nice
optimistic ending it doesn't matter who
you are you can be someone this
completely negates that though and says
nope you better hope you're part of one
of the two families that matter in these
movies otherwise he completely useless
Rey in the force awakens was desperate
to find out who she really was
and you know what's more devastating
than finding out that you related to the
big bad guy in the galaxy finding out
you're absolutely no one that isn't
important at all who tied to the Emperor
makes her know she's special whereas
it's much crueler for her to not be it
also makes her taking down the first
order all that much more important
because they underestimated this poor
scavenger girl but hey let's go with it
Rey was a Palpatine and Luke and Leia
knew the entire time
now why I have a big problem with this
is because Luke himself had something
hidden from him when he was growing up
that was used against him in a battle
and it completely blindsided him when
talking to obi-wan post battle of bespin
Luke was furious that he'd not known
about his father
so you think going forward he wouldn't
want to do the same to someone else but
nope they're not gonna tell ray and
they'll hope that someone doesn't use it
on her in a battle and completely throw
her off again
Palpatine wasn't supposed to be tied to
right at all and everyone behind this
movie they know it the movie is so
desperate to right the wrongs of the
last Jedi that it throws shut it we
Luke mocking throwing the lightsaber
away and Rose being reduced to nothing
Rose came in as a spacecraft expert and
they even have a moment in the movie
where they're talking about the ins and
outs of the Star Destroyer fleet that
Rose could have been a big part of but
they give the dialogue to someone else
they say that Palpatine has also been
conjuring up the Sith fleet for the
final order so like does that mean he's
been making them out of thin air why not
make it that star where's he getting
these materials from how come no one's
noticed this whereas soldiers coming
from how's he feeding them do they just
live on star destroyers didn't any type
of crystals of power the Death Star how
did Palpatine get enough for every ship
though anyway what's worse than one Star
Destroyer ten million star destroyers
why can't they just use the old
Lightspeed trick that whole dough did in
the last Jedi what because it's a
million to one chance but it was a one
to one chance in that movie why do they
not have shields till they leave the
planet well why not just have more than
one beacon on the ship anyway look the
majority of the plot of the movie is to
just go from one item to the next to
find out how to get to the next item
that you want to the film moves faster
than Lightspeed skipping and because of
this a lot of impactful moments feel
like they don't get the weight or
breathing room that they deserve
speaking of Lightspeed skipping I
thought they could only track you
through Lightspeed if they had a massive
computer on a battleship not a TIE
fighter never mind
the pace would be fine but they actually
spend more time on pointless things that
get undone over big moments that need
more room for example the fake death of
c-3po gets way more time than the real
death of Princess Leia this was a
perfect moment to pay tribute to Carrie
Fisher who sadly passed away recently
and this could have been a chance for
everyone to get a goodbye they don't do
that though she's killed pretty randomly
and it doesn't really have that much
impact in the entire movie Chewbacca
also gets a big death fake-out that
doesn't hold up upon a rewatch so
according to the film he was taken on a
ship an identical one then landed at the
exact same spot and then that tried to
take off because of reasons right well
there's no stakes in that emotional
moment because Chewbacca isn't
and it repeats the fake out of the quote
unquote death of c-3po in my opinion a
lot of emotional beats bother Han and
been seen feel like they didn't really
have the time to develop them so the
creative team just skipped over them
this is exemplified by Finn who at the
moment he thinks he's going to die cries
out to Rey that he has something to tell
her though this is touched upon we never
find out what it is and thus it's
completely pointless being in the movie
especially with this being the last time
that we'll likely see the characters my
guess is that they wanted Finn to reveal
that he loved ray and then decided to
edit it out because they'd left too much
lip service to it and the rest of the
movie and it was pretty much impossible
to remove there's actually a thing in
film studies called Chekhov's gun which
is a concept that describes how every
element of a story should contribute to
the whole it comes from Anton Chekhov's
famous book of writing advice that says
if in the first act you have hung a
pistol on the wall then in the following
one it should be fired this Finn moment
it doesn't contribute anything to the
film it feels like a pointless line and
ends up going absolutely nowhere the
film also focuses heavily on force
healing which though it's appeared in
the Mandalorian feels like it breaks the
universe if you can force heal someone
then why didn't L be one user on qui-gon
why didn't Luke user on Veda and so on
and so forth force healing is a
get-out-of-jail-free card that
retroactively Lee cheapens the other
films and makes it just look like the
characters were idiots it's only been
introduced here because yeah they didn't
know what else to do maybe it's been
working in the shadows this entire time
I don't know why did the resistance know
it take horses on ships why didn't the
Star Destroyer just turn slightly and
tip them all off the side another thing
that feels very forced is Zuri blesses
magic space coin that grants access to
any ship in the first order why would
the first order allow for such a thing
to be made that can integrate into their
systems
why didn't why why don't any of the
soldiers look out the window while
the ships docking and be like hmm this
ship looks a bit suspect I mean I know
they're using the magic coin to bypass
our systems but maybe we shouldn't let
them on like I refuse to believe that a
magic coin was the best idea that they
had genuinely throughout Star Wars has
been several times where characters have
had to get onto ships and they haven't
had to resort to such a force plot
device such as a magic coin that one of
the characters that they randomly bumped
into you just so happen to be carrying
how is the Emperor back again oh you
don't have time to explain because you
too busy setting up this magic space
coin right got it
anyway why did Zoe bliss live ohnkoji me
for decades hating that she was stuck
there then decide to leave moments
before it was blown up I don't know
another big MacGuffin in the movie is oh
jeez Syd dagger the apparent ancient
dagger somehow also managed to line up
with a wreckage of the second Death Star
and as long as he was standing on an
exact cliff at the exact spot that the
Death Star fell you'd be able to see
where to find another MacGuffin which
was the wayfinder I have no idea how
this ancient dagger managed to predict
where the Death Star would fall exactly
but let's say it was made after The
Return of the Jedi
why is this thing that contains such
valuable information being carried
around as a weapon why is it not a fault
why is it being used to start people why
can see 3pl read what it says but then
not say it why not just remove that
programming it entirely as you clearly
don't want him to ever reveal what it's
a so yeah just stopped him from being
able to read it before the movies
release it was marred with reshoots and
I think after the huge success of
endgame that they tried to alter the
ending in order to copy several iconic
moments the arrival of Lando and the
fleet is very similar to Falcon saying
on your left I've just realized it's
Falcon and Millenium Falcon
Palpatine says I am all of the Sith and
rey says I I in I mean the Jedi and the
entire enemy force gets dusted after one
swift and decisive move this ends the
threat of the Sith but why Khan
Palpatine just returned down the line
now that you brought him back once that
there's no real finality to his death
and he could just be out on another
planet
the resistance celebrate and we get our
big LGBT moment that Disney have been
talking about for months I mean they're
so progressive in everything as long as
it's not a main character and it's
something that they can easily edit out
for China but yeah very progressive guys
I'm straight so I can't really give my
personal opinion on this but I can't
imagine that with this moment being
hyped up for months now that many
members of the LGBT community will be
disappointed with the lack of
representation here
it feels like they just wanted to tick a
box so they threw it in at the last
minute and it doesn't really feel all
that sincere Lando and Jana sit down to
talk and originally in the leaks it was
at this moment that they were going to
realize that they were father and
daughter and that Lando had remained a
person or after his child was kidnapped
by the first order there was some
rumblings that Disney were just being
lazy and making it so that every black
character was related so apparently they
removed it which again I think negates
the movie as it does feel like they were
setting up for this scene and even
during the scene where the two talk it
does feel like they should acknowledge
it but but something happened in editing
there we then cut Turay out Luke's old
moisha form so firstly how did she know
that Luke lived there
secondly who the hell is this old woman
just walking around where has she come
from
where did she go where did you come from
cotton-eye Joe what is she doing there
who is she
what why does she just so happen to be
in this position so that she can ask Rey
who she is I'll tell you why
lazy writing ray turns looks about
smiles and then says ray ray Star Wars
now ray turns and sees Luke and Leia but
at this moment I really think that she
should have seen Ben and Anakin there
too you know the complete Skywalker
family finally reunited in the afterlife
looking over her as she takes up their
name and goes forth into the galaxy this
is the rise of Skywalker and it just
feels like they needed them there in
order for this to possess more meaning
also what the Knights of Ren were in
this movie when the Knights of when I'm
gonna call them I think overall whilst
it's fine that people love the movie for
me there's just too much here not to
ding it it feels like a lot of pandering
to audiences
and there's no real ingenuity here
because it's all things that we've seen
before JJ is just content with pandering
and he's actually pandering so much
right now that he's even come out and
said both people who like and dislike
the movie all right in their opinions
which yet is getting beyond parody the
movie failed in China which is actually
kind of interesting because the original
films were never released there so it
just kind of shows how much audience
connect with the movies because they're
banking on nostalgia obviously though I
would love to hear your thoughts in the
film and if you loved it
I appreciate you sitting through this
video for this long probably disagreeing
with everything that I've said so here
it is your chance to sound off and let
me know why you like the movie if
there's anything you dislike that I
didn't touch upon then make sure you let
me know as this will be the last rise of
Skywalker video that I do my channel on
the whole is very positive towards
movies and TV shows and I'd much rather
talk about good things and slam them so
I'm signing off on this topic right now
if you want to come chat to me after the
video that make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my discord server which would be
linked in the description below we drop
videos on there early so if you want to
see stuff before anyone else and that's
the best place to be it's free adjoining
we have an awesome community so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
Joker which is one of our favorite
movies of the air and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on the rise of Skywalker in the comments
section below
but when it's gonna be chosen at random
on the 15th of January and the cell be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]
you